votre succès ne cessera de m'étonner
vous êtes une vraie star parce qu'en
2023 vous allez être au centre Vidéotron
et au Centre Belge vous êtes parti d'un
garage assez Philippe à montréji comment
vous vivez ce succès
écoute je sais pas comment je lis le
d'un je suis vraiment mêlée
[Rires]
je pense je le vis bien je le vis mieux
et quand ça a l'air vraiment décoller je
m'attends mon premier tout le monde en
parle c'est des grosses crises de
panique sur Walmart parce que là le
monde me reconnaissait le monde me
toucher le monde me parler moi j'étais
habitué à mon petit crowd sur Internet
qui me suivait depuis un certain temps
là ça va mieux j'ai apprivoisé ça j'ai
apprivoisé la bête mais au début c'était
plus compliqué je
lorsqu'on tape Roxane Bruno sur Google
on voit que tu déménager parce que
certains fans venaient sonner chez toi
comment te vécu se déménagement là c'est
comme une pression énorme oui mais je
pense ça c'est pas de la bienveillance
c'est ça c'est un infime pour 100 pages
de ce que je vis enfin oui j'ai déménagé
parce que là il y avait beaucoup de
monde qui savaient où j'habitais mais
c'est pas trop le monde qui venait chez
nous c'est arrivé trois fois quatre fois
c'était peut-être les mêmes
moi j'ai déménagé aussi parce que
c'était le temps c'était pas juste ça
qui m'a fait déménager c'était juste la
cerise que faite déborder mon Sunday ça
doit être effrayant là dormez la nuit et
puis
constamment peur mais je dormais avec un
petit bâton de golf
sérieusement
là j'avais un sac de golf je voulais
rien savoir de ne je voulais la gloire
et Rocky side la carrière et la vie de
Roxane Bruno est racontée dans tes
chansons je pense à je suis pas stressé
tu dis que tu as lâché l'école l'emploi
pour vivre le grand rêve ça a pris
beaucoup de courage à quel moment ça
s'est passé puis pourquoi faire ce choix
là
j'avais pas de scolarité enfin que je
travaillais dans une pizzeria après ça
je travaillais dans un centre d'appel
il y a rien là-dedans pour moi qui
pouvait me faire il y avait rien
artistique dans tout ça c'est même
plaçais les pepperonies de façon comique
une fois de temps en temps mais
c'est courageux oui puis non parce que
j'avais quand même un producteur qui me
disait c'est bon là tu peux l'enlever ta
job
de ce que tu me dis là parce que moi
j'ai des affaires à payer parce que
quand même quelqu'un qui m'a dit ça va
être correct
sur les internets
Roxane Bruno l'humoriste sur internet
mais il y a un talent certain il y a un
don pour écrire des blagues
vraiment dur merci beaucoup il vient
d'où ce talent là
depuis tout petit depuis tout petit que
je fais de l'impro et du théâtre
puis je sais pas j'ai vraiment commencé
sur internet de même le fait que c'est
comme si j'avais fait des bars mais sur
Internet c'est un bon humoriste il rôde
son stock il va dans les bars il fait
ses numéros puis réécrit et puis moi je
l'ai fait sur internet en faisant des
vidéos puis ça c'est moins drôle c'est
moins bon
j'ai fait mes courses seul chez nous
finalement
premier album 2017 dysphorie vidéo clip
des petits bouts de moi avec au compteur
11 millions de visionnement et c'est une
vidéo qui fait du bien parce que elle
met en scène une histoire d'amour entre
deux femmes aussi pour vous c'est
important de parler de ce thème là et
libérer une certaine parole je voudrais
avoir l'air d'être seul de la fille pour
qui c'est important mais c'était juste
naturel j'ai même pas j'étais très très
jeune et très naïve au début ça ça a été
filmé c'est vraiment pas de budget il y
a pas de personne qu'il faut que je
fasse un clip c'est toutes de mes amis
personne n'était payé il y a pas
d'éclairagiste
à la voix comme je te pose l'autre c'est
avec mon téléphone puis c'était même pas
dans le but de je veux montrer deux
femmes qui s'aiment c'est juste ce mot
ma réalité je sers les gens vous savez
ce que je trouve super intéressant c'est
que oui vous avez des vidéos clip
tournée ou iPhone le deuxième album a
été enregistré dans une douche je pense
que c'est un message pour les jeunes qui
ont des chansons qui veulent créer que
tout est possible finalement en 2022 je
pense qu'avec Internet toutes nos
téléphones cellulaires là tu peux juste
filmer 10 secondes mais ça sur Tik Tok
puis tu sais s'il y a vraiment c'était
du talent si les gens voient si
quelqu'un te remarque moi c'est ça c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a remarqué sur Internet
qui m'a appelé puis j'ai fait un album
cette semaine tu as sorti deux chansons
en exclusivité sur ce sport de fil bah
tu sa sortie cette semaine il y a des
artistes qui critiquent beaucoup à ces
réseaux de musique en continu en disant
que ça va tuer la musique québécoise
parce que ça peut pas assez de redevance
un sujet qui est très chaud qu'en
penses-tu
je trouve que je suis la pire pour
parler de ça en ce moment
parce que moi j'ai pas juste cette
plateforme là tu comprends c'est mes
taux ni jouent à la radio j'ai beaucoup
de vues sur Youtube enfin je me verrais
mal commencé à faire ça a pas de bon
sens parce que le monde va écouter ceux
qui vont faire
la privilégié l'autre
c'est pour ça que je comprends je
comprends sauf que moi en ce moment je
peux pas me plaindre je crois que ça me
Bruno continue de faire les choses à ta
manière merci beaucoup pour cette
entrevue merci
[Musique]